thanks a lot I'm Tim fried the director
the Herman Institute and I'm really
honored to welcome gary shteyngart the
award-winning author and Herman faculty
member he'll read from his newly
released memoir falooda chica little
failure which published with Random
House as you all know he's written three
highly acclaimed novels and now he's
turned to nonfiction writing in this
memoir and we have books for sale in the
back and we also want to thank Gary for
sitting for an interview for our
Harriman magazine which will be out
shortly in which you can get either in
hard copy or you can pick up on our
website shteyngart was born in soviet
leningrad where he spent seven years as
a child and he was fiercely devoted to
Lenin and his role Dina then now he
moved to Queens in New York finished
oberlin college and he then became most
well known as a prodigious bluebird and
he's also fine time on the side to write
three highly acclaimed novels the
Russian debutantes handbook where we
meet vladimir skin the fan man and the
Bronze Horseman which has been
mysteriously removed to Prague then we
have absurdist on where we meet Alyosha
Bob Misha vineburg the son of the 1238
richest man in Russia and that conniving
Jerry Stein Farb and of course the
mountain Jews who save our hero then in
super sad love story we see in New York
of the not too distant future where
Staten Island is hip and there are
credit poles hanging around the city
which reveal the passers-by net worth so
you can figure out whether you need to
ignore the person or not and each of
these novels we get writing which one
critic wrote was a combination of
Nabokov and Woody Allen which I think
really meets the really i think hits the
target very well so without further ado
I give you gary shteyngart who will read
from little failure
thank you for that introduction can
everyone hear me is this okay yeah okay
whoo great to be here Columbia I teach
you I think right okay it's slowly
surprising yeah and good to be back in
the Morningside Heights it critics have
agreed that the best thing about this
book is by far the cover it's a picture
of me I'm about a year and a half old in
Leningrad 1974 and they had these photo
studios where you could put your child
with the latest in Soviet technology in
this case it's this studebaker Volga
actually and there's various pictures of
me in different poses crying in front of
here I'm crying in front of a telephone
for example so the pictures are the best
part of this book and only until this
year at age 41 that I finally learned
how to drive I was always so scared of
automobiles so watch out New York
seriously watch out a terrible terrible
driver um people the book is really
about how I became a writer and and
people often ask me that question I
teach at the Creative Writing Program at
you know across the campus um how do you
become a writer well first to become a
writer you have to be very asthmatic
there's no way around that you got to
have asthma quite badly um so I would
grow up in a cold damp place like
Leningrad which is actually built over a
swamp so it's perfect and in 1974 in the
so Union there were no steroid inhaler
for asthma so you really got to see
mortality up close as a child because
you're always about to die um I still
remember the whale the ambulances in our
courtyard always coming to take me away
to the hospital very good stuff for a
writer then you got to have a
grandmother who writes my grandmother
Gaia was a journalist for a paper called
evening Leningrad the chair Nadine
breath and which is much better than a
morning Leningrad that was lord of the
TMZ of
yeah I mean that joke in LA and then I
realize don't have the audience right
but we're in safe ground here in New
York so one thing when I was five years
old my grandmother said to me hey asthma
boy you know you want to be a novelist
new and she said I'll give you a piece
of cheese for every page you write and i
love that at cheese that kind of
plasticky yellow Soviet cheese and right
outside the window was the biggest
statue of Lenin in Leningrad for those
of you who know the city its Moscow sky
blue she's beautiful statue we called
them the Latin Lennon because he always
looked like he was about to rumba here
this sort of so every morning when I
wasn't dying from asthma I get up and I
would hug Lennon around this pedestal
that's how much I loved him so my first
novel for my grandmother was called
Lenin and his magical goose and in it
Lennon meets a goose possibly from
Armenia or Georgia someplace warm and
together they invade Finland and try to
create a socialist revolution there then
Lennon the goose get into a huge
political fight one of the first
pictures in this book is me wearing the
typical thing that you wear is a five
year old Russian child which is a sailor
outfit this alone constitutes about
seven years of psychoanalysis and i'm
reading this hefty Talmudic tome which
is actually all about the Civil War of
1979 like most Soviet kids obsessed with
the Civil War of 1917 so in my book they
fly to Finland they start the socialist
revolution that goes well but then we
find out that the gooses menshevik and
lenin of course is Bolshevik so Lennon
eats the goose and my grandmother loved
it but she said you know um said well
maybe he doesn't eat the goose maybe he
exiles the goose to Mexico and ice pick
ice pick you know and she picked me a
hundred pieces of cheese for the hundred
page novel and even today Random House
pays me and cheese so there's a kind of
symmetry there and then we emigrated to
America and we had to leave linen behind
and I had to learn English and also some
Hebrew because I was sentenced to eight
years of Hebrew school for
crime I did not commit hey you know and
1980 was a difficult time to be a
Russian in America remember Ronald
Reagan's evil empire speech and all
those movies red dawn red gerbil red
hamster everything was red you know and
I pretend to the kids in Hebrew so that
I was actually born in East Berlin not
in Leningrad you know things are bad
when you have to convince Jewish kids
that you're actually a German plus we
were really poor I had one shirt one
pair of pants and a bunch of t-shirts
that the parents of the kids in Hebrew
school had donated and my toys were a
pen and a Chewbacca action figure
someone had given us that was missing
half of his paw and I had come from
Russia so you know I had a fur coat and
a fur hat made out of some woodland
animal and the teachers were actually
take me aside and say you really need to
get rid of your fur kids will play with
you more if you're you know furless
which is actually true and adulthood as
well haha and then two years after we
left Russia something truly an
incredible happened that almost changed
our lives forever and I'll be you this
section and then two other sections from
the book in 1981 an official letter
arrives in our mailbox mr. s cart
you have already won 10 million dollars
sure our last name is misspelled rather
cruelly but cardstock this thick does
not lie and the letters from a major
American publisher to wit the publishers
clearing house I opened the letter with
shaking hands and a check falls out paid
to the order of s cart 10 million
and 0 0 / $100 our lives are about to
change I run down the stairs into the
courtyard of our apartment complex mama
Papa we won we won me million earring we
are millionaires with Spock oi sent my
father says calm down do you want
another asthma attack but he is nervous
and excited himself talk talk let us see
what we have here around the glowing
surface of the orange dining table
imported from Romania we spread around
the contents of the voluminous packet
for two years we have been good new
citizens watching x-rated movies with
titles like a manual the scent of a
woman getting jobs as engineers learning
to pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of American and for
the something for which that it stands
unavoidable with money for all boyfriend
muy my mother says my god as we look at
the pictures of a Mercedes flying off
the deck of our yacht toward our new
mansion with its Olympic size swimming
pool boy does it have to be a Mercedes
pool Nazis don't worry we can trade for
a Cadillac boardroom Oy how many
bedrooms does this house have seven
eight nine you said the kids at school
have houses like this and all Papa this
one ours will be bigger well the way I
understand it the house doesn't come
with the prize the prize is just 10
million dollars and then we buy the
house separately to they always say here
sold separately you can forget about the
yacht Gary it's dangerous but I know how
to swim mama how do you keep the pool
open in winter maybe the houses in Miami
I want to live in Miami maybe there
aren't Hebrew schools in Miami
everywhere in America there are Hebrew
school we sit down on using our
collective collective 400 word english
vocabulary begin to unravel the many
documents before us wait it says here
that yes we have already won the 10
million dollars no disputing that but a
panel of judges still has to award the
money to us first we must fill out the
so-called winners form and to select
five national magazines that will be
sent to us free or at least the first
issue of each will be free and then the
Americans will likely send us the rest
of the 10 million dollars fair enough
first we must a'kla meet to our new
wealth expand their literacy I am proud
of Papa's new car a bulbous 1977
chevrolet malibu classic with only 7
million miles of the odometer but it's
time to get acquainted with the finer
autos so i order car and motor motor and
driver carburetor and driver muffler and
owner and for the last selection
something that has my Star Wars monkey
Chewie Chewbacca in it Isaac Asimov
science fiction magazine I walk solid me
to the mailbox and deposit or claim on
the future Adonai elohaynu I pray to our
new God please help us get that new 10
million dollar
so that Mama and Papa will not quite so
much and there will be no toss for
divorce between now and let us live
somewhere far away from Papa's wolfish
relatives who caused all the trouble and
let them not yell at mama when she sends
the money Papa says we don't have to her
sisters and grandma guilin leningrad who
has been dying for a very long time man
that night in my dreams I walk into the
solomon schecter school of queens on
multi-millionaire and the pretty girl
with the big teeth who's always tan from
florida vacation kisses me with those
big teeth i haven't gotten the mechanics
of kissing down yet the kids make fun of
jonah Himelstein the school's biggest
loser but I say Hayes my friend now here
is to dollars by us both the car Bell
flying saucer cookie ice cream and keep
the change you burnished you nothing hey
we find out the truth quickly and
brutally at their respective workplaces
my parents are told that the publishers
clearing house regularly sends out that
you have already won 10 million dollars
missive and that these are routinely
thrown in the trash by the savvy
native-born depression settles over our
non millionaire shoulders and Russia the
government was constantly telling us
lies wheat harvest is up who's Beck baby
goats give milk at an all-time high
Soviet crickets learn to sing the
Internationale in honor of Brezhnev's
visit to a local hay field but we cannot
imagine that they would lie to our faces
like that here in America the land of
the this and the home of that and so we
don't give up hope entirely the judges
are probably reading our application
right now maybe I should write them a
letter in my burgeoning English dear
publishers clearinghouse spring is here
the weather is warm and rainy birds come
from south and sing songs my mother's
pianist fingers hurts very much from her
typing clerk job and she has only one
suit for work please send us ten million
dollars immediately we love you family
fine guards hey meanwhile car in parking
and the other publishers Clearinghouse
magazines are starting to pile up
taunting us with the many hot naked
centerfolds of the new Porsche 911 the
official sports coupe of Reagan era
excess we reluctantly begin to cancel
our subscription to all of them except
for Asimov science fiction magazine
in a small square little number with the
drawing of an exciting molting space
creature on the cover hugging a boy just
like me in its claws our dreams of being
instantly rich are finished but we are
moving up nonetheless we are saving
every kopeck that comes our way via my
father's junior engineering job and my
mother's typing here's our inventory I
have my pen my broken shoe bunk
Chewbacca monkey my recently circumcised
penis the Mozart candy wrapper from
Vienna Airport my Soviet Atlas and a
bunch of donated t-shirts my mother has
hurt us eyes to harv Bernard business
suit my father has made a fishing rod
out of a stick pounds of disgusting
markdown farmer's cheese and caution
with fetus until we die of sadness and
if I don't clear my plant my plate of
that warm crap the thunderclap of Papa's
hand rings against my temple my mother
yelling just don't hit his head he's got
to make money with his head or Mama's
week-long silent treatment will make me
consider taking my own life altogether
who are we parents may bid Nia we are
poor folk why can't have two bucket with
both paws parents we are not americans
both paws but you both have jobs parents
we have to buy a house yes a house the
first step to Americanism who needs two
handed Chewie when we will soon have our
own Kwazii suburban home but at
lunchtime the Hebrew school boys do like
to take out their Luke's and obi-wan's
and Yoda's and set them on their desk to
demonstrate just how much property falls
within their purview they talk and
they're already raspy Jewish voices I
throw out my old Yoda because the paint
on his ears was falling off and then I
got two new ones and a princess leia
just so ham solo could do work me amazed
wow so um I wrote Lenin and his magical
goose because I wanted all that Soviet
cheese but i also wanted my grandmother
to love me and that was the easiest way
to get her love and so the terrible
connection was forged in my mind that
writing novels equals love what was I
thinking you know today most novel and
start exactly loved or read even I gave
a reading at a university a few years
ago I'm not going to mention the
University of Oklahoma by name
but his student there said you know
excuse me mr. Shekhar how do I know when
a books been fiction and made it and I
said what and she said I know like when
it's not true and I said well it says
novel or stories on it you know she says
well thank you i'm going to avoid those
from now on because i only want things
to be true and so i'm proud to have my
first nonfiction in the book with me
today I'm sure it's selling big in
norman huge and norman seller all of my
books I'm big in norman but back to life
after not winning the Publishers
Clearing House sweepstakes because I was
the the red gerbil the second most hated
boy in Hebrew school I thought what if I
wrote a science fiction novel and showed
it to all the kids in school maybe
they'll learn to like me and these
specimens still exists my parents were
kind enough to save them hundreds of
pages and little child scroll this one's
called invasion from outer space take a
look inside chapter one something is
wrong and boy was it you know someone
called child services and then when I
was about 11 years old a momentous thing
happened in the guise of a substitute
teacher at Hebrew school called miss s
and one of her first days on the job
miss s asked us all to bring in our
favorite items in the world and to
explain why they make us who we are I
bring in my latest toy a dysfunctional
Apollo rocket whose capsule pops off
with the press of a lever but only under
certain atmospheric condition humidity's
must be below fifty four percent and
explain that I have even written by own
novel this part passes largely
unremarked as the latest batch of Star
Wars x-wing fighters and my little
ponies are paraded around finally miss s
holds up a sneaker and explained that
her favorite activity is jogging PU a
boy cries out pointing at the sneaker
and holding his nose as everyone except
me laughs they're wicked child laughs I
am shocked here is a young kind pretty
teacher and the children are intimating
that her feet smell only me and my
200-pound Leningrad fur are allowed to
smell around here I look to miss s so
worried that she will cry but instead
she laughs and go ha goes on about how
running makes her feel good
after we have all finished explaining
who we are mrs. calls me over her desk
you really wrote a novel she asks yes I
say hmm it is called the challenge may I
read it yes you may read it i will bring
kit and bring kit i do with the worried
admonition please don't lose me says
okay and then it happens at the end of
the english period when a book about a
mouse was somehow learn how to fly in an
airplane has been thoroughly dissected
miss s announces and now Gary will read
from his novel is what oh but it doesn't
matter because I'm standing there
holding my composition notebook straight
from the square deal notebook people of
Dayton Ohio zip code for 54 63 and
looking at it near the boys beneath
their little flying saucer you are
malukas and the girls with their sweet
aromatic bangs their blouses studded
with stars and there's miss s who I'm
already terribly in love with boo hoo I
recently learned has a fiance not sure
what that means can't be good but whose
bright American face is not just
encouraging me but priding me on am I
scared no I am eager eager to begin my
life introduction I say the mysterious
race before the age of dinosaurs there
is human life on earth they look just
like man of today but there were a lot
more intelligent than man of today
slowly miss s has read slowly Gary let
us enjoy the words I breathe that in
Miss s wants to enjoy my words and then
slower they built all kinds of
spaceships and other wonders but at that
time the earth circulon because the moon
was bigger than the earth one day a
gigantic comet came and blew up the moon
to the size it is today as I'm reading
it I'm hearing a different language come
out of my mouth I do full justice to the
many misspellings the earth circulon and
the Russian accent is still thick but
i'm speaking in what is more or less
comprehensible english and as i am
speaking along with my strange new
english voice I'm also hearing something
entirely foreign to the squealing and
shouting that constitutes the background
noise of my Hebrew school silence the
children are silent they are listening
to my every word and they will listen to
the story for the next five
weeks as well because miss s will
designate the end of every English
period as Gary novel time and they will
shout out throughout the English period
when we're Gabby veto vetti the school
was closed to Long Island and I will sit
there in my chair oblivious to all but
Miss essa smile excuse from following
the discussion of the mouse who learned
how to fly so that I may go over the
words I will soon read to my adoring
audience and God bless these kids for
giving me a chance may their God bless
them everyone so in the meantime because
most Soviet immigrants are quite
conservative I've subscribed to another
little magazine called the National
Review William F Buckley Jr editor
Margaret Thatcher on the cover on every
cover and then I'm sent a thick card
featuring an American Eagle sitting upon
two rifles that's right gary shteyngart
age 11 is being welcomed into the
National Rifle Association can't start
too soon with the NRA my republicanism
flourished even as I left the provinces
of Eastern Queens and ended up at
Stuyvesant High School the holding pen
for multi multi national math and
science nerds in Manhattan and then my
political political allegiances
underwent a change and it happens like
this on Election Day 1988 i come to the
marriott marquis ballroom thinking this
is the day the day i will finally get
laid i have volunteered for george bush
senior scorched-earth presidential
campaign against the hapless Michael
Dukakis laughing along with bushes
racist hysterical Willie Horton
commercials and all they imply about the
liberal massachusetts Greek compassion
after all as a virtue only rich
Americans can afford tolerance is the
purview of slick Manhattan heights who
already have everything I want I'm
invited to attend what is sure to be a
Republican victory party at the marriott
marquis the ugly slab of a building near
Times Square the invitation to the party
features a scornful cartoon of the big
year Dukakis sticking his head out of an
m1 Abrams tank the most unfortunate
photo op of the campaign and I expect an
evening of arrogant crowing of being
pressed to the bosom of my fellow
conservatives while dancing a Protestant
hora over the grave of American
liberalism yes tonight is a special
night
it's the night I'm to meet a Republican
girl from a clean white home her name
will be Jane Jane Carruthers let's say
hi Jane i'm gary shteyngart from Little
Neck my family owns a dutch colonial
we're 280,000 US dollars I'm the brains
behind a Commodore 64 program called the
family real estate transaction
calculator i go to Stuyvesant High
School where my grades aren't so great
but I hope again into the honors college
at the University of Michigan I guess
tonight is going to be curtains for the
governor of taxa chusetts hehehe I enter
the ballroom a dark gap-toothed
immigrant wearing sweat socks and brown
penny loafers and my special and only
suit a highly flammable polyester number
i navigate the room filled with
sparkling anglo-americans clutching
single malts without a word said in my
direction without a pair of happy blue
eyes reflecting the gray sheen of the
crisp my line tie i had bought for two
dollars from a Broadway vendor as George
Herbert Walker Bush racks up state after
States on the big screen above us as
cheers and laughter circulate around the
massively hideous ballroom I stand alone
in a corner biting down on my plastic
cup filled with ginger ale and swatting
the colorful balloons that seem to have
an affinity for my static inducing
polyester until a pair of teenage blonde
lovelies the girls I've been waiting for
all my life finally approached with
needy smiles on their faces one of them
beckoning for me to come hither with her
hand I'm so excited I somehow failed to
see myself for who I am a short teenage
boy born to a failing superpower trapped
inside a shiny gunmetal jacket carrying
about a mop of the darkest hair in the
room darker even and michael dukakis as
hellenic do which one will be my chain
which one will trace the w of my weak
chin with her puter fingers which one
will take me on her boat and introduce
me to the millionaire and his wife you
know something daddy Gary survived
communist Russia just so you could join
the GOP I think that's very courageous
son would you like to throw the old
pigskin around me with me and Jack Kemp
after cocktails just leave your top
siders in the mud room hey one of the
lovely says me debonair and concern hey
so I'll have a rum and coke just a
splash of ice and a lime manda you said
no ice right she'll have a diet coke
lime no ice I've been mistaken for the
waiter and the next thing I'm a Democrat
amazing others work it have been in the
tea party by now like so many relatives
of mine and for the last section I
thought I'd just backtrack to our first
days in America you know coming to the
country in 1979 from the former Soviet
Union wasn't just crossing a time zones
it was being teleported to a different
and much better planet it was felt like
a pure science fiction movie a kind of
advanced civilization the first
chevrolet corvette that you saw thinking
it was an airplane without wings the
first momentous thing that happened to
me in kew gardens queens is that i fall
in love with cereal boxes we are too
poor to afford toys at this point but we
do have to eat cereal is food well sort
of it tastes grainy easy and light with
a hint of false freeness it tastes the
way America feels I'm obsessed with the
fact that many cereal boxes come with
prizes inside which seemed to me an
unprecedented miracle something for
nothing my favorite comes in a box of
Assyria called honeycombs a box
featuring a healthy freckled white kid
whom I begin to see as an important role
model on a bike flying through the sky
what you get inside each box of
honeycombs are small license plates
which can be tied to the back of your
bicycle the license plates are much
smaller than the real thing but they
have a nice metallic F to them I keep
getting Michigan a very simple plate
with letters on a white letters on a
black base I traced the word with my
fingers I speak it aloud getting most of
the sounds wrong me who gone what I need
now in a very serious way is to get an
actual bike in America the distance
between wanting something and having it
delivered right to your living room is
not terribly great I want a bike so some
rich American neighbor they're all
unspeakably rich gives me a bike
arrested red monstrosity with the spokes
coming dangerously and done but what do
you want I tied the license plate to the
bicycle and I spend most of my day
wondering which plate to use citrus
sunny Florida or snowy Vermont
this is what America is about choice I
don't have much choice in pals but
there's a one eyed girl in our building
complex whom I've sort of befriended
she's tiny and scrappy and for just like
us we're suspicious of each other at
first but I'm an immigrant and she has
one eye so we're even the girl rides
around and a half broken bike just like
mine and she keeps falling and scraping
herself rumor is that's how she lost her
eye and boiling whenever her problems
get blooded bloodied her blonde hair
raised up to the sky one day she sees me
riding my bang the bicycle but the
honeycombs license plate clanging behind
me and she screams Michigan Michigan and
I ride ahead smiling and Tooting my bike
horn proud of the English letters
they're attached somewhere below my ass
Michigan she screams Michigan with his
bluish-black license plate the color of
my friends remaining I Michigan with its
delicious American name Michigan how
lucky one must be to live there thanks a
lot that was fantastic will now have a
time for some questions so I you'd like
to line up behind the microphone or if
you're close if you could just speak
really loudly that would that would work
too while you're all gathering your
great thoughts I have I have a question
Oh complaints i would say usually i get
a lot of those how dare you so um you
clearly have a lot of fun poking fun at
academics in academia right throughout
your works this is a theme and having
been in academia i can see there's a lot
lot of material there but now you're on
the other side has this changed your
thoughts at all or well I was afraid to
write about academia until I got tenure
now sky's the limit um you know I mean I
Kadeem is fascinating because you get a
bunch of really smart people often doing
things that aren't so smart that to me
is absolutely wonderful and
you know the my favorite novel and I
teach it I teach a class called the
immigrants agogo which is sort of
immigrant writers you know being
themselves and one of the my favorite
novels probably if you know the world is
the book opening which I teach with
great relish which is of course a novel
set in waynedale college or Cornell as
it was better known and the book of its
that's my favorite novel I've always
wanted to write something like that the
problem I think is nobody wants an
academic novel anymore i think afternoon
after a postcards from an institution
after David lodges holes oubre there's
really not much room left for a funny
academic novel which is too bad now
Booker was an amazing instructor I wish
that I spoke with his accents it could
tell my students the kind of things he
said he had a poetry student one point
who said you know mr. no but mr. nabi
you know how do I become a poet and the
book have pointed to a tree outside the
canister what is this and the guy said
well it's a tree in the book have said
you will never be a poet so now with
tenure I'm allowed to do that and also
to come in not wearing a shirt make sure
all important things but I love academia
it's nice to be here I teach one
semester ii or night you know it's weird
i kind of almost miss it when I'm not
here the camaraderie is great they're
smart people all we need is for
Morningside Heights to have food that's
you know Adam and then then we will then
I could live here forever oh yeah please
hi hi um so one of the lens from your
book says born to a failing superpower
there's a recent poll done within Russia
that said a large part of the population
believes that it's returning to
superpower status and the title of this
article is actually Russian society
experiencing delusions of grandeur yeah
I just curious what your thoughts are on
that yeah it's an interesting thought
you know uh just I think yet last year I
was in Moscow or a year and a half
before the recent fun stuff happened and
I was being driven to shitty Mitchell
and the airport and the cab driver was
drunk out of his mind and crying you
know luckily the traffic moves you know
at one kilometer an hour but he was
crying as I can't feed my family I'm
trying so hard I can't feed my family I
want to move to the United States but I
know it's hard to get a visa etc and I
said you know really loves immigrants
and who has a great you know which is an
even richer country per capita at this
point isn't Haneda you know it's cold
it's wonderful and he looked at me
drugged me said who I can only live in a
superpower you know that was incredible
ahead the Russian approach to it I mean
honestly who cares if your country
dominates the world or it's just doing
great you know Allah Canada or Denmark
etc it's fun for us as people are
interested in policy to be close to a
central like Washington or while New
York Washington that whole corridor that
seems to rule a good chunk of the world
but honestly you know if I was if
America fell apart I had to move to
Vancouver I'd be okay you know they're
really good Cambodian and Indian food I
would survive you know but that whole
mentality which which is very surprising
but this is sort of the crux of writing
this memoir was the idea that I was born
to one superpower which fell apart and
now I live in another superpower which
is not doing so hot so everywhere I go
the superpower collapses you know they
will let it let me land in China anymore
just so worried about whatever contagion
I have
to them but it's it's it's an
interesting idea this idea of Russian
grandeur which you know the country
simply can't match economically or even
demographically I mean you know the
nicest thing about Crimea was at least
I'd added to millions by people to an
ever-diminishing population so this may
be the only way that Russia can sustain
itself is by taking chunks of Kazakhstan
and all these other or pacman style all
these wonderful wonderful Republic's
that are just so edible and filled with
Russians please oh oh please yeah I'm
dead with it you can good yeah well look
this book has been translated but the
others have been translated do they
people read them not really a small
weird fringe maybe in Moscow and
Petersburg the reviews are always like
balding traitor betrays mother lands
that was a positive review and timeout
Moscow and it's all downhill from there
you know like shteyngart pleases his
American masters I'm like I wish the CIA
paid me or anything you ended that is is
whatever Liberty radio helped me anyway
so yeah the views is pretty cynical 11
review was very funny because it was
this guy sort of a moaning it was when
absurdist and came out which did the
best out of all of those books obviously
and and so and his complaint was he
could live in Moscow and make fun of us
but he lives in New York and that's a
kind of podiatrist of a kind of you know
betrayal you have to live here and
suffer alongside us if you're going to
do this kind of thing makes sense you
know I kind of understood his thesis
statement actually it's a kind of a
follow up yeah I didn't answer a piece
of him sorry yeah but I was going to ask
if there are any plans for your book to
be translated into Russian and if there
is if you would actually take part oh
you know all three book you mean this
book ya know this book has nothing
all to the rights but the other three
books are translated into Russian by in
their translations of various quality
depending on the different translators
who have done it and my real question I
guess is also you know you obviously
very have a very humorous approach and
you're the kind of bittersweet quality
to your writing but I was wondering if
during the writing if anything was
actually kind of painful to recount or
unpleasant or just heavy you know I'd
say all of it was perfect can you be
more sustainable to recount I mean look
this is the book that has a three page
long adult and life later life
circumcision scene it's painful yeah
it's you know it's a lot of my bumper
sticker doesn't say ask me about my
child's honors courses asked me about my
late in life circumcision people stop
and ask yeah look if you're going to
write a memoir it's not going to be it's
like wasn't funny enough you shouldn't
write a memoir if it wasn't tragic
enough you shouldn't write a memoir
either I think the best memoirs marry
cars liars club Frank McCourt's Angela's
Ashes are incredible expressions of both
humor and deep sadness and the sadness
is not just you know the respective
dysfunctional homelands you come from
Texas Ireland's in my case the Soviet
Union and then Queens it's it's really
it has to be about family circumstances
it has to be about families that through
society or through any other reason are
not are functioning with both a lot of
love because without the love it just
becomes caricature a lot of love and
also a lot of culture clash what's funny
about touring with this book is you know
the Americans will get up and
native-born Americans will get up and
say oh my god a little failure that's
what your mother called you that's
unconscionable and
why can you across the head and then the
Russians will come and say yeah that's
my nickname too and can you sign this
too little failure / failed paralegal
last for brains and others will say
I did everything they wanted I married
who they wanted I became the lawyer they
wanted me to be and I'm still a failure
you know so it's the reaction has been
very different among different different
groups and I think that that that
Russians really do think of this the
ones I me as a kind of I mean that's
been very touching to forget Oh as one
woman said you are our Judy Blume you
know that is high praise indeed thank
you well the super sad is the one
they're trying to turn into a TV series
so we're working very hard on that that
would be amazing with James Franco's
Joshi and Paul Giamatti as Lenny would
that be amazing writing is interesting
you know I wake up pretty late are we
covering 11 you know a hobble I write in
bed so I never leave bed someone
delivers food to me it's very a blob of
like you know there's a lot of not
moving my posture is not great i have a
very weak upper back and weak lower back
and weak side back door so i'm barely
alive at this point it's fun to write in
bed and do other you know just to be in
bed all day long at 5i see my shrink
from five to six a lot of authors do and
a lot of them see on the upper east side
so it's six everyone gathers at cafe
Sabarsky for some cafemad schlag and
then that's a dinner until eight eight
to eleven is drinking 11 is the crying
our this is
writers realize that nobody really wants
to read books anymore and we are so in
the wrong profession so that lasts for
the crying hour until midnight and then
we walk home and then wake up at eleven
eleven hours of sleep the Beautyrest
that provides no beauty and then the
process begins again so that's pretty
much the horror of the writing life
today others I teach at some point too I
don't even know what can we just start
the part of the evening where we just
tell me you how much we love you unless
thank you love super sad true love story
and and going back to the sadness / love
what I love also is the generosity that
you offer to other authors I'm speaking
of someone trying to write a book like
the fact that you always say positive
things about writing and about authoring
just like you to address that thank you
thank you that's very sweet of you to
say when I started out writing you know
I really did think of writing as my own
relationship with others as being the
sort of blood sport where writers you
know if this rate each other and I wrote
two reviews that I'm not proud of which
were reviews that focused on the stuff
that I found lagging in a book and I had
a professor who was through egging me on
saying yeah it's what's the blade more
just just let them and then I realized
why God you know we're all in this
together it's not that people shouldn't
write critical reviews reviews should be
critical but as much as we can support
each other the better the pie is small
that doesn't mean that we should stab
for the pie with with ellen gated Forks
you know I think rather it means that we
should all help each other out so i
retired from blurring this week because
things just got out of hand but i did
manage to blurb 150 books which is I
think a world record I will continue to
blurb books I just issued in The New
Yorker and manifest overall continue to
blurb all my Columbia students will
always be blurbed students of my work
with my editor agent will always be
blurred owner of long-haired dachshunds
will be blurred anyone Ukraine will be
blurbed as recompense for what's
happening
anyone whose first name is Daria or last
name as Lipschitz will be so there are
still categories that I would learn but
it's been a hell of a ride you know 150
books I've read a lot of them the rest
looked good you know like good covers
attractive authors etc you know how
could you say no so but thank you but I
do you know I doing this 150 date or
whatever the hell I mom you know seeing
readers is very it breaks my heart it's
just so wonderful Philip Roth once spoke
to that you know he said yeah nobody
reads but you know if you sell 30,000
copies of a book which back in the day
was nothing these days is a lot he said
just picture 30,000 people walking past
you you know in talking to you and
that's just a beautiful thing to think
about and me yes
broadsky that was cool yeah this
actually goes back to a question I fail
to answer from you awesome yeah look
Nabokov obviously as a craftsman is
somebody that I've read quite a bit you
know when it so much of my work is
trying to connect with my parents in
some ways and not understanding who they
are and in in a way of weird bridge so
that has been said gave lots of us work
which and he used to live in the part of
our sales in rego park and I just met
his daughter she was sitting next to me
out of fundraising I blurb his book of
course I me was were lots of and it's an
amazing it's a Pushkin Hills which is
not even my favoritest book i love
compromise in a stronger these are
hilarious books that are really straddle
that kind of culture so the plot of and
then moving forward the usual cast of
characters at the countess daya so token
as a satirist you know he is the one
that you look to and he's been able to
predict the ridiculousness of putin
error rule with such incredible panache
and i'm sorry the first what do I see
yes the do I see myself ever being in
the Sochi Olympics no no obviously not
am I in the tradition of Russian writers
only to the point that i love the
Russian language so much and that it has
been in these four books to such a large
extent I've taught American readers how
to curse in Russian and I feel that
that's an important achievement they go
around slinging these words you know
with abandoned and so it's wonderful you
know you see someone in st. Petersburg
sitting at a at the idiot cafe reading
absurdist an and and and learning how to
use the words correctly that's been fun
but look I let's be honest I mean I'm
not I'm someone who came here at age
seven I still speak the language because
my parents speaking because I go back
every year but so much has been lost
that connection has been lost a long
time ago I find Russia to be a very
difficult country in which I couldn't
raise a kid just
a kid and I just I couldn't do that to
him you know life is so short and but I
will say this that the Russian love of
literature is Russia's most wonderful
point about Russia you know once I
rockin wrote a global solid blue lard
this book there was an iconic scene of
worship and Stalin making love and
hundreds and thousands of pensioners got
upset Stalinist pensioners because
krisha was on top of Stalin and not the
other way around so they built a giant
wooden toilet outside of the bull show
in which they flushed down symbolically
copies of blue lard this means they seem
horrible to us but in what other country
does literature matter enough for
pensioners to build a gigantic wooden
toilets outside of the preeminent
cultural institution and flush down
copies of someone's work on the other
hand I was invited to speak at st.
petersburg state university one of them
two main universities in Russia on
literature and I was very scared because
I thought here was a a room full of
women because men don't bother with the
humanities in Russia you know so a room
full of women their boyfriends and
leather jackets were standing outside
waiting for them to be finished with
this crap and i was expecting these
really tough questions about serfdom and
you know to gain yups view Alexander the
second whatever and but the first
question was the beautiful woman gets up
and says so uh avatar are they going to
make that into a novel or what hahaha
and I thought well you know it's really
over for literature on both sides the
ocean
next I'll be like Tommy away from
somewhere the first thing I was working
on and I think I out of the times your
next one is going to be a female
protagonist ex-fianc professional turns
yeah baby for years they may got it
wrong two thousand i have published
every four years before your plans sure
sure well i wanted to do something
different after a memoir which is
intensely about me i thought hey enough
about me let's deal with somebody else
so i wanted a character who's everything
I'm not a woman I had a lot of fun with
super sad true love story writing about
a korean-american protagonist I think
this one would be half Korean American
half I haven't thought maybe something
like Canadian hey because i love skewer
in canada got into this whole I offended
Canadian literature terribly through a
tweet or something no I got drunk and I
said something in an interview and so I
had to fly to canada and apologize to
the Ontario Arts Council talk about
people that take literature seriously so
maybe half canadian so i could skewer
them some more and have korean and i
want to set in a lot of financial
capitals shanghai mumbai do buy anything
with an eye at the end will be fun I do
a lot of travel writing so I have all
this experience and travel and being in
all these different places and I kind of
wanted to put it to good use and but I
just wanted to have a woman sort of what
going around place is killing people
which is so different from what I do in
little failure which is just slowly
killing myself but it's fun to change
things around soon action go in the back
first and then in the front
well
all right like the broad see ya I don't
listen to lupe all day long if that's a
quick do i watch it I've seen some of
them you know that in books there was
all those stupid you know bungie's
keeping your book type books it's just
in the culture everyone knows that you
put on my land mine and blow people up
you know that's sort of intrinsic
Leningrad Petersburg knowledge people
have how do you dispose of somewhere you
know so it's just following the news was
a lot of it i still i love reading you
know Sloan org I see after all that
stuff but in the 90s of course it was a
lot more exciting I mean there was what
was that firefight i cant rember the
name of the was the street was right in
the center of town we were these two
cars and nobody wanted to give away and
they just started shooting each other
you know it's fun I've always loved the
American Mafia tradition The Sopranos is
the end all be all for me of so I was
exciting to see this happen in a land
that I'm you know ten gently involved
with and and you know this the whole the
brats of I and stuff I aids I love it
when they started wearing better clothes
you know and moved to London I think
that was a really exciting thing for me
when that you know the tracksuit gave
way to the izod that was an impressive
movements in Russian history
well in my immigrant agogo class we
teach we start with the book of spleen
no we started we start with Henry Ross
college sleep which is incredibly
beautiful self-hating emigrant stuff
then we get to the book of Spain which
is my book of love themselves too much
to be a self-hating immigrant but then
we really delve into the couch at Chiang
raleys native speaker which is about a
self-hating Korean immigrant then Junot
Diaz is drowned there's a lot of good
stuff out there and do I see myself as
part of that kind of yeah really very
much so yeah we have an incredible
following an American among American
readers because Americans don't like
books and translation that's too weird
you know it's not even in English
originally but the immigrant serves as a
nice kind of bridge between you know so
they're here they're not smelly anymore
and they speak in our language so let's
read that and we can laugh along because
they hate themselves as well so that's
been good that's been really a good
career move I think
drunk out of my mind I have a series of
photographs with me and my best friend
in his he lives in cucina which is this
godforsaken part of st. Petersburg and
oh my god these selfies are out of
control just different parts he's
Ukrainian so we go the good ilka route
and that's that ilka is pretty
impressive than yeah because it's hard
to deal with it without that kind of you
know you need to medicate almost
immediately but I bring American drugs
into it you know ativan lorazepam xanax
so I like to diversify when I'm there
I'm never happy there but it's always
been I mean again you know this next
book probably a little maybe be a
chapter about Moscow but pretty much it
won't be about Russian themes but you
know in dealing with Russia I've had to
go there all the time and that takes a
lot of emotional and psychological
effort because I'm at the place i'm at
the ground zero we're all where my
parents became who they are my parents
by the way I've not read the book they
don't read English that well so
hopefully they'll never read it because
hopefully America translate into Russian
so win-win for me but I do like to you
know the books I've written about Russia
celebrate the maximalist part of the
Russian spirit and that requires a kind
of lubrication and and you know getting
you know three in the morning somebody
gets up on top of a statue of a tank
somewhere in the middle of nowhere and
delivers a speech about their mother and
that's our mothers in general or women
you know these broad categories and that
to me is his life in Russia yes
oh yeah very useful degree yet you can
end up here and I that's good that was
yeah this is by the way oh and I really
appreciate that thanks a lot this is say
this guy got a move on right very simply
how did I make that decision parents it
was my pre-law type thing I went to the
Overland Institute for special people
whatever the where everyone majored in
you know Gary studies are there you know
the Beatles but I had to have a real
major and you know it was obvious to my
parents that couldn't do med school
that's that was their preference you
know but too dumb for med school so what
is he going to do with his life the
parents in Russia all he says who are
you by profession even today they would
ask but who are you by profession I'd
say I'm a writer but no but really what
do you do you know so you know to my to
my parents doing a pre a poli-sci was a
concession saying hey we're spending a
hundred grand you're at barnard
according your sweatshirt right it was
probably about 200 grand now right so
back then in the 90s was only 100 you
were spending under grand what the hell
you know what are you gonna do with your
life as I said I'll have a minor in
creative writing which is what I really
wanted to do but I'll major in poli-sci
and it was hilarious because it over
when it was all Marxist professors and I
talked about this in little failure how
they had you know there was the people's
adi TT audi TT roadster the people's
espresso maker with a big red star on it
and we tried to reconcile Marxism with
our spectacular lifestyles and it took a
lot of doing but I almost I'm glad that
I majored in something other than
English for creative writing and that I
had a understanding of the world a
little bit you know that's my
recommendation to writers is to have a
world that's outside of writing so
you know look at Chekov you know being a
doctor how much that helped him
understand the world and be close to the
world get a medical degree if you want
to be a writer it's always good to mix
it's always good to have a profession so
poli-sci you know whatever economics
that that's a good thing to have to
understand how the world works now that
I'm writing this book that has all these
financial elements God how I wish I'd
taken more than just intro to econ my
life would be so much easier now I'm
like a student with you know 10 dozens
of textbooks trying to figure out you
know how you know financial meltdowns
occur boy it's complicated
summer has been so proud of you or has
reinforced your pride for it just it
keeps on going you know it's it's
there's a restaurant in Petersburg
called 1913 and I asked the owner wyd
1930s it was the only good year in
Russian history you know it just it just
keeps on giving you know the satire of
it the outrageousness of what's
happening now in the Ukraine you know
what was that joke you were telling me
okay so Putin is on the phone and he
says no I want you to move your border
away from our tanks that's what I loved
one of the first jokes i remembers a
challenge is growing up you know my
parents would tell his prayers nip jokes
this is nineteen eighty the bridge and
the Moscow Olympics a Brezhnev is
completely senile barely life this body
has to give a speech so he locks up to
the podium you probably know this
choking and he has a piece of paper in
front of me he starts reading and oh and
his assistant ren substances no comrade
general secretary those are just the
Olympic rings it's a great joke and the
fact that these jokes continue to me
that's Russia so you don't want to live
in it but you know you want to observe
it and you wanna because it's just it's
so such rich material and what else do I
love about it the language continues to
just hearing people talk in the street
and get very emotional in America you
hear people and speaking Russian but
it's this quazy Russian English you know
that you know but in Russia it's well
it's there's a lot of English words to
you know Jordan Lee PR and stuff like
that but it's it is wonderful but it's
sad you know because it took one step
forward two steps back you know it's
just there's never any discrete feeling
of hope and the mentality doesn't change
it changes for a select group of you
know middle class Muscovites who are you
know internet-connected and know which
protests to go to and things like that
but for the best you forget that you
know outside of mosca there's this
gigantic country attached to it which
has a mind of its own obviously and so I
get I really do get depressed and even
you know I always limited myself to 23
weeks but boy when I pass bulk of a
control and that Austrian airliners
humming away and I just think I'm God
again you know I'm gone and then I come
back ten days of a uterine and then back
to being me whatever that is now no he's
six months old my wife is a
korean-american so they would have to be
Russian and Korean which is too much so
he'll just learn Mandarin like everyone
else so food features very prominently
in your work yeah so where do you eat in
New York unless you have like secrets
you don't want no yeah I'm a huge eater
um thai food is one of my favorite foods
um uncle boons on Spring Street is
amazing you got to try it out I always
get the name wrong I love a really spicy
Thai papaya salad sometime dare which is
on Avenue A and I think sixth Street has
the spiciest papaya salad the best food
is always in Queens well there's a great
Korean restaurant that's a fort lee fort
lee new jersey of a korean food monaco
sigh which is 35 West 35th Street has a
really good short ribs and and micro
brisket which is a very thinly sliced
brisket Russian food just isn't good so
don't use it oh they opened up the
branch of that restaurant in Moscow the
Ukrainian one tennis thats boohbah yes
where I went before all the
unpleasantness happens that's so what
the food that i love so much is sala
which is just lard
and and and when I was growing up my
father would tell me these stories
called plan yet does read off the planet
of the Yids which would be a planet's
this is when he would take me around and
this is how I began sort of a satirist
is he would tell me these stories of a
planet of Jews living on this planet who
were constantly being bombed by lard
torpedoes sent out by the space slobs
and the Jews were protected by captain
Sharansky and all this talk about lard
torpedoes made me very hard and hungry
for lard so that's a great place to get
large and to pay penance for the nation
okay good any thank you very much any
other questions I don't wanna I just
wanna thank you who's there one more
okay down please the major question yes
uh oh business school is good yeah most
of my writing and jokes are outsourced
to India so they're they're actually
funnier than I am ha that's the best
question I think I I don't know funny I
had funny parents you know they're very
funny even even in their cruelty they're
funny like failure chicken was my
mother's nickname for me little failure
you know that's pretty funny or my
father called me snotty those are funny
you know depressing but funny things
that humor is only funny when there's
something tragic behind it you know so
that's why Jews are so good at humor
it's this kind of humor from the edge of
the grave but humor is very hard to get
I don't understand I'm very bad at you
know like I lived in Italy for a while
and I would look at how
in shows on you know on TV and I thought
we saw that the humor was just so non
sophisticated compared to our daily show
or you know Colbert Report it was always
so slaps they can so based on physical
comedy which is the lowest form unless
it's done really brilliantly by Chaplin
escalate people I have to do an article
for GQ where I have to hang out in with
the Chinese comedian in Beijing for like
a month and I speak of course no
Mandarin so this would be all right
they'll be explaining the jokes to me
like three ways through but I want to
like what's funny in China I want to
figure that out you know it maybe
improve upon it because i was listening
to their already playing some jokes for
me and like this all is about you know
like how people in shanghai do this but
let people in chengdu do that you know
and i'm like oh that doesn't sound that
funny right because that's very
elemental humor but coming from a
messed-up society does help you want
some kind of laughing at leaders is
great you know when when w you know when
the w era was over I was like oh no as a
satirist I mean Obama has been fun too
but as a satirist you know humor works
really satire really works best when
evil and stupidity collide ya know that
is great and and Russia does that you
know in spades so that's what I would
look for but good luck I mean I think
it's sweet that you want to step into
the shoes of funny yeah so I want to
thank everybody for coming we've got
books for sale right and we've also got
that interview with Gary that's coming
up in the air and magazine I wanted to
plug both of those but also i want to
thank gary shteyngart think
horn nature yeah call me a good yeah
thank you all for coming thank you very
much